.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hauptbahnhof Zürich.
Der Kabarettist, Schriftsteller
und Musiker Franz Hohler
macht sich auf den Weg
in seine Heimatstadt nach Olten.
Ich sass schon als Kind
immer gerne im Zug.
Meine Eltern erzählten einmal,
sobald der Zug losfuhr,
fing ich an zu hüpfen,
aus Freude, dass wir jetzt fahren.
Mit 60 denkt man, man sei schon 60
und bald komme die berühmte
Pensionierungsgrenze 65.
Mit 70 denkt man:
"Gut, bis jetzt ging ja alles gut."
Ich wartete mit 70 eigentlich
immer noch auf die Pensionierung.
Die kam einfach nie,
auch mit 80 nicht.
Aber es ist völlig klar,
dass der Vorrat an Zukunft schmilzt.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Im Moment
habe ich kein literarisches Projekt.
Und das belastet mich
überhaupt nicht.
Im Gegenteil,
jetzt habe ich Zeit, aufzuräumen.
Das ist mein nächstes
grösseres Projekt.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass ab jetzt
nichts Grösseres mehr kommt.
Ich habe genug gemacht.
Franz Hohlers Lebenswerk
besteht aus 14 Kabarettprogrammen,
17 Theaterstücken, etwa 60 Büchern,
mehreren Hundert Fernseh- und
Radiosendungen und einem Spielfilm.
Zum 80. Geburtstag
schenkt ihm seine Heimatstadt
gleich mehrere Ausstellungen.
Dafür werden Manuskripte,
Bühnenrequisiten und Raritäten
aus seinem Zuhause in Zürich Oerlikon
in den Kanton Solothurn gebracht.
Ich suche gerade den einen Text,
den ich ihnen mitgeben möchte.
Hier habe ich "Der Weltuntergang",
auch in einer Urfassung.
Denn heute kommen die Leute
vom Historischen Museum.
Die wollen mich ausstellen.
Damit ich nicht selber gehen muss,
gebe ich ihnen Sachen mit.
Hoffentlich reisst sie nicht.
# Wie glücklich ist ein Mann,
wenn er allein zu Hause ist.
# Und halbverbranntes Rindfleisch
mit Spaghettiresten isst.
Furchtbar.
Ich müsste wirklich wieder üben.
# Ein Essen zäh wie Leder,
# aber dennoch eine Pracht.
# Er hat es selber gemacht.
Furchtbar.
Das klang fast poetisch.
* Applaus *
Franz Hohlers Haus
ist vollgestopft mit Requisiten
aus fast 60 Jahren Künstlerleben.
Seiner Frau,
der Psychologin Ursula Hohler,
wurde es oft zu viel des Guten.
Manchmal reichte es mir schon.
Bei "Drachenjagd" meinte er,
wir könnten doch im Garten
ein Häuschen
für den Drachen bauen.
Ich sagte Nein, da verstauten wir
den Drachen im Keller,
in der Waschküche.
Jeder Gegenstand
erzählt eine Geschichte.
Die Ausstellungsmacherinnen
haben die Qual der Wahl,
aus der Fülle einen repräsentativen
Querschnitt zusammenzustellen.
Begonnen hat Franz Hohler
seine künstlerische Karriere mit 22.
Der Erfolg
seines ersten Soloprogramms
war für Franz der Auslöser,
das Germanistik- und Romanistik-
Studium an der Universität Zürich
an den Nagel zu hängen.
* Energievolle Big-Band-Musik *
Es war sicher sehr wichtig,
wie ich aufwuchs.
Dass ich in einem musischen
Elternhaus aufwuchs.
Meine Mutter spielte Geige,
mein Vater war literaturinteressiert
und schrieb selber Texte
und spielte Theater.
Ich erlebte Kultur
als etwas Selbstverständliches.
Als etwas, das gelebt wird,
nicht als Fassade.
Ich glaube,
das erleichterte den Einstieg
in die Welt als freischaffender
Fantasiearbeiter sehr.
* Lockere Hackbrettmusik *
* Applaus *
Dann gehen wir nach oben damit.
- Ja.
Auch das "Filmchischtli",
ein Kultrequisit
aus der Fernsehsendung "Spielhaus",
soll in Olten ausgestellt werden.
(TV) Ein Haus,
eine Tür, ein Fenster -
eins, zwei, da sind sie -,
kommt rein, es ist deins,
es heisst "Spielhaus".
Hey, René. Kommt noch etwas?
Warum schaust du noch?
Stell das weg und warte.
* Räuspern *
Ab den 1980er-Jahren führt der Autor
Tobias Wyss im "Spielhaus" Regie.
Hier stand die Kiste.
Die Konstruktion
wurde einfach nur hingestellt.
Mit dem Podest.
Und da fand es statt.
* Engelhafter Gesang *
Franz schrieb es
und trieb das Ganze voran.
Aber im Prinzip
basierte es auf einer Freundschaft.
Es ergab sich eine Freundschaft.
Ich bin mir sicher,
dass sich das in den Sendungen
widerspiegelte.
Und das bereitete den Kindern
und allen zu Hause eine Freude.
Und mir und ihnen
beim Machen natürlich auch.
Grüezi, heute erzählen wir etwas,
spielen und räumen auf.
Also erzählen tue nur ich.
Ich bin Franz.
Der dort drüben ist René.
Der sagt nichts.
Ich sage nichts.
- Hast du doch etwas gesagt?
Mit dem Hemd
und dem Gilet, das ich hatte ...
... und die Schuhe dazu
habe ich auch noch.
* Lustige Musik *
Über 20 Jahre
beglücken Franz und René
kleine und grosse Fernsehzuschauer.
Hohler arbeitet immer wieder
gerne mit anderen Künstlern.
Zu einer herausragenden
Zusammenarbeit
kommt es Anfang der 1970-er Jahre
mit Emil Steinberger.
Nein, Entschuldigung.
Irgendjemand trat gerade
auf Franz Hohlers Cello.
Niemand will es gewesen sein.
* Lautes Lachen *
Die Untersuchungen laufen noch.
Er wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
eines aus Ersatzholz basteln.
Soweit ich sehe, ist er schon dabei.
* Klopfen *
Er macht also ein neues Cello,
aber mich nimmt wunder, wer es war.
Es war dunkel,
darum merkte man es nicht.
Hauptsache,
er kommt bald mit einem neuen.
# Wie freut sich erst ein
frischgebackener flinker Ehemann,
# wenn er der Frau den neuen
Kühlschrank übergeben kann.
# Er stösst den Stecker ein,
# das Kabel raucht,
der Anschluss kracht.
# Er hat ihn selber gemacht.
Noch heute sind Emil und Franz Hohler
befreundet.
Hohlers Vielseitigkeit
beeindruckt den Luzerner
Kabarettisten immer wieder.
Er ist genial, er ist ein Genie.
Das stellte ich
in letzter Zeit fest.
Es ist unglaublich,
was Franz alles gemacht
und angerissen hat.
Auch politisch.
Er war ja sehr stark tätig.
Das bezog sich auf den Chemieunfall
von Schweizerhalle.
# Es isch nüt passiert,
es isch nüt passiert.
# Es isch alles wunderbar.
# Nur ganz es bitzli isch dernäbe,
doch das isch zuemuetbar.
das isch scho zuemuetbar.
Sie erinnern sich wahrscheinlich,
am 1. November 1986
wurden einige Hunderttausende Fische
im Rhein vergiftet.
Sie gingen am Wasser zugrunde,
das plötzlich in ihre Kiemen gelang
und nichts mehr
mit Wasser zu tun hatte.
Es waren 943 t Agrochemikalien.
312 t sog. Formulierhilfsstoffen -
was auch immer das ist.
Aber Sandoz ging in sich
und lernte etwas daraus.
Sie stiftete einen Forellenteich.
Sie nahm gefährliche Stoffe
aus der Produktion.
Abgesehen von denen,
die in die Dritte Welt gehen.
Aber es soll ja hier besser werden.
Heute trete ich auf als Restrisiko.
Brennstäbe schmelzen
und Natriumbrände.
Plötzlich berstende Reaktorwände.
Computerfehler
für Erstschlagbefehle.
Und leckende Gase und Gifte und Öle,
ist alles hier drin.
Nehmt ihr alles in Kauf.
Wollt ihr mal sehen?
Dann mach ich es auf.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Ihr Restrisiko.
Hohler ist einer der ersten Schweizer
Kunstschaffenden,
der das Gefahrenpotenzial
der Kernenergie thematisiert.
Er engagiert sich
für den Umweltschutz,
mischt sich
in den politischen Alltag ein,
polarisiert und wird zur Reizfigur.
Könnte man
nicht den Krieg überspringen
und mit den Hilfsprogrammen
anfangen?
In der Kinokomödie "Dünki-Schott"
kämpft er unter der Regie
von Tobias Wyss
wie einst Don Quijote verbissen
gegen Windmühlen unserer Zeit.
Ergib dich, du trostloser Kerl!
Missglückter Zaubertrick!
Pestbeule vom Juranordfuss!
Arschbacke des Teufels!
Das Problem war,
dass wir nicht wussten,
ob es ein grosser Spielfilm war,
oder ob es eher
etwas Improvisiertes war.
Franz war ja der, der er war.
Er ist ein wunderbarer Improvisator.
Als Schauspieler war er das,
was er halt war.
Dann machten wir den Film.
Dann kam er ins Kino
und lief einigermassen gut.
Dann gingen wir im Januar nach
Saarbrücken an ein Filmfestival.
Wir gewannen den Publikumspreis.
Es gab also doch Leute,
denen er gefiel.
Leider wollte das Schweizer
Fernsehen ihn nicht ausstrahlen,
da sie es nicht zeigen wollten.
1983 weigert sich
das Schweizer Fernsehen
eine Folge
der Satiresendung "Denkpause"
zum Thema Dienstverweigerer
auszustrahlen.
Es kommt zum Eklat.
# Dir gseht, dass i schribe.
# Chönnd s Lese au la bliibe,
dir heids ja süsch scho schwär.
# I danke euch für d Charte.
# Dir wüssed, die vo wege,
und han üch welle säge,
# dir chönned uf mi warte.
# Dr oberschti Visionär,
i wirde nid Soldat.
# Vollbring ke Heldetat
i oisem Militär.
# Sell nid persönlich si,
# doch hani mi entschlosse,
s wird weder ziilt na gschosse.
# I rücke gar nid ii.
Ein Thema, das die Programm-
verantwortlichen des Fernsehens
ihren Zuschauern
so nicht zumuten wollten.
Haben Sie bewusst provoziert?
Wollten Sie, was jetzt herauskam?
Genau so wollte ich es nicht.
Ich unterscheide bei mir nicht
zwischen Politiker und Satiriker.
Mein Bestreben ist eigentlich
ein ganzer Mensch zu sein
und als ganzer Mensch
meine Sachen auszudrücken
und zu gestalten.
Das kann lustig und satirisch sein,
das kann aber auch ernst sein.
Für mich gehört zu dieser
Vierteilstunde eine Offenheit,
die gross genug ist,
damit so etwas möglich ist.
Wenn Sie in unserem Medium arbeiten,
wissen Sie,
dass es eine Konzession gibt,
die den Rahmen vorgibt.
Darum wussten Sie ziemlich genau,
worauf Sie sich einlassen.
Aus Protest
wirft Hohler das Handtuch.
Sechs Jahre später kommt er
mit einer neuen Satiresendung
zurück ins Fernsehen.
Im Theater
läuft es für Franz Hohler besser.
Oft und gerne tritt er
im Luzerner Kleintheater auf.
In der heutigen Vorstellung
spaziert er durch sein Gesamtwerk.
Das Kleintheater Luzern
ist für mich ein spezieller Ort.
Das gründete Emil 1967.
Er fragte mich,
ob ich auftreten würde.
Ich trat dann auf,
und von da an war ich ...
Es war einer der Orte,
wo ich gerne immer wieder hinging.
Dann lernte ich Emil kennen.
Vorher hatte ich ihn erst einmal
im Radio gehört
und hatte
ein Programm von ihm gesehen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
er mache Dinge,
die ihm nicht so liegen.
Dann begrüsste er mich
und gratulierte zum Programm,
fragte dann aber sofort,
wer diese und jene Nummer
geschrieben habe.
Ich sagte ihm,
ich hätte sie selber geschrieben.
Da sagte er:
"Emil, du musst alle Nummern
selber schreiben."
"Das ist so auf dich,
deine Art zu spielen
und deine Stimme zugeschnitten -
das musst du machen."
Dann fügte er noch hinzu:
"Und wenn du mal
ein Programm schreibst,
kannst du mir sagen, wenn ich
helfen soll. Dann komme ich."
Wenn ich manchmal eine Nummer
für mich überlege,
kommt es vor -
eigentlich so oft wie möglich -,
dass Franz Hohler
mein erster Zuschauer ist.
Er sitzt dann hier unten
und ich probiere auf der Bühne
gewisse Szenen aus.
Seine Reaktionen
sind sehr massgebend.
Wenn er lacht, lacht das Publikum
später sicher auch.
Wenn er gar nicht reagiert,
war es wohl eine schlechte Leistung.
Ja, er war eine männliche Hebamme,
indem er das wirklich
bei mir aus dem Körper holte.
Ich habe mir vorgestellt,
ich sei der Personalchef,
der ein Inserat
für einen Autoverkäufer aufgab.
Er sucht einen Autoverkäufer,
und er meldet sich
wegen des Inserats.
Wir haben das noch nie gemacht
und spielen das zum ersten Mal.
(Gleichzeitig) Grüezi.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
- Brumm.
Herr Brumm?
- Ja.
Grüezi, Herr Brumm.
- Wumm mit Vorname.
Wumm Brumm?
- Ja.
Seltsamer Vorname,
aber Sie sind Schweizer?
Ja.
- Das ist wichtig.
Was mich interessieren würde:
Könnten Sie einen Kunden überzeugen,
ein Auto zu kaufen?
Ja, sofort.
- Ja?
Ich habe Leute schon
für anderes überzeugt.
Sie haben ein Wissen ...
- ... in der Autobranche. Ja.
Auf dem Sektor schon, ja.
- Jawohl.
Sie wissen, was eine Kupplung ist
und was z.B. Vergaser sind?
Ja.
Die Kupplung,
wenn der Kofferraum aufgeht.
Das sind diese Arretierstangen.
Ein Klassiker aus seinem Repertoire
darf auch in Luzern nicht fehlen.
Wenn wir so schön beisammen sitzen,
könnte ich zum Schluss noch eine
Berndeutsche Geschichte erzählen.
Es isch zwar
es bsungers uganteligs Gschichtli,
wo no gar nid eso lang
im Mittlere Schattegibeleggtäli
passiert isch.
Dr Schöppelimunggi
und dr Houderebäseler
si einischt schpät am Abe,
wo scho dr Schibützu
dürs Gochlimoos pfoderet het,
über s Batzmättere Heigisch
im Erpfetli zueglüffe.
Das wusste ich lange nicht.
Sein "Totemügerli" ist ja
eine reine Fantasiesprache,
entstanden aus dem Berndeutschen.
Das ist eine Leistung.
U so isch das hin u här gange
wie nes Färegschäderli
amene Milchgröözi.
Da seit plötzlech dr Houderebäseler
zum Schöppelimunggi:
"Schtill!"
"Was ziberlet dert näbem Tobelöhli
z grachtige n uuf u aab?"
Schöppelimunggi
het gschläfzet wie ne Gitzeler
u hets du o gseh.
Es Totemügerli!
Dann noch auf Romanisch.
Als ich die Nummer
auf Rumantsch sah,
konnte ich wieder voll lachen.
Duraint üna not,
schlorza da plondscher charbuns,
duos tschaggelaris givettain
aint illa stüvnaunca.
Cu splavettan ad ün plötz
ün mortunzel.
* Hämisches Lachen *
Fin da l'emissiun.
* Lachen, Applaus *
Die Villa Alpina
ist über 100 Jahre alt.
Dieses Kleinod
mitten in Zürich Oerlikon
ist Franz Hohlers Rückzugsort.
Hier wohnt und arbeitet er.
Das Haus war ein Glücksfall.
Vor 45 Jahren.
Vorher wohnten wir
in Uetikon am See.
Wir hätten schon lange
aus dem Haus gemusst.
Wir waren immer Nummer 2 oder 3.
Hier waren wir dann plötzlich
Nummer 1.
Und ich war so nervös,
dass ich
am Morgen der Besichtigung meinte,
ich käme nachmittags noch mal
wegen der Pläne.
Ich rannte zur Bank
und sagte der Dame am Schalter,
die ich gut kannte
und die mich auch kannte,
ich bräuchte 30'000 Fr.
Ich bräuchte es
für eine Anzahlung an ein Haus,
vielleicht
würde ich es morgen wiederbringen.
Da fragte sie,
wo denn das Haus stehe.
Da meinte ich, in Oerlikon.
Und sie: "Ah, in Oerlikon."
Da wusste ich,
dass wir richtig sind.
Ich hätte Zollikon oder Küsnacht
sagen sollen.
Dann hätte sie gestrahlt.
Zum lauschigen Garten
gehört ein Holunderbaum,
der Franz besonders lieb
und teuer ist.
Nachbarin Regula Läuchli,
eine Freundin der Familie,
assistiert ihm, wenn er mit seinen
80 Jahren auf die Leiter steigt,
um für die Sirupproduktion die
letzten Holunderblüten zu pflücken.
Ich kenne Franz und Ursula,
seit ich auf der Welt bin,
da sie mit meinen Eltern
in Uetikon am See
in einer Hausgemeinschaft lebten.
Es war natürlich auch speziell,
dass Dimitri ein- und ausging.
Hannes Wader, Mani Matter ...
Diese Leute erlebte man,
an Feiern oder an Wochenenden.
Das führte auch dazu,
dass mein Vater
Mani Matter engagierte
und wir den Schicksalsschlag
von Mani Matter
sehr nahe miterlebten.
Das gehört zu meinen
ersten Kindheitserinnerungen.
"Ich habe einen jungen Freund."
"Mit dem ich gerne diskutiere."
"Nachts vor allem."
"Er ist gescheit und witzig,
fasst, was kompliziert ist,
rasch zusammen
und entlarvt, was einfach ist,
als kompliziert."
"Dichter ist er,
und mit ihm Metaphern, Wortwahl,
Versmass, Reime zu besprechen,
ist Genuss."
"Doch kann ich über Menschliches
genauso mit ihm reden,
über Frauen, Sehnsucht, Krankheit,
Sorgen, Neid und Zweifel."
"Und wir können lachen
wie die Kinder."
"Er ist schon mehr
als fünf Jahrzehnte 36 Jahre alt."
"Seit jenem Abend auf der Autobahn."
Sie kannten ihn, Mani Matter.
Übrigens führte er sein Soloprogramm
zum ersten Mal
nicht etwa in Bern auf,
sondern hier im Kleintheater Luzern.
Emil hatte ihn durch
beharrliches Fragen dazu gebracht.
# Ich glaub,
mir hend etzt all di nötig Schwäri.
# Drum gömmer alli hei
und morn id Ferie.
Da hat es auch noch eine.
Das muss noch für die letzte Portion
Holundersirup reichen.
Bei euch seid ihr noch nicht fertig.
Nein, aber wir sind auch etwa
in der Hälfte.
Schauen wir,
ob alles gut eingehängt ist.
It's okay, it's alright.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht nervös.
Ich habe etliche Viertausender
bestiegen.
U.a. Piz Bernina
über den Biancograt.
Und ich bin
überhaupt nicht schwindelfrei.
Die lasse ich fallen,
dann heben wir sie nachher auf.
Der Holunder
gilt eigentlich als Schutzpflanze.
Und zwar gegen Blitzschlag.
Ja?
- Ja.
Ich habe ja
ein Grimms Wörterbuch.
Das ist das grösste Wörterbuch
der deutschen Sprache.
Hohler - alter Name des Holunder.
Ist nicht wahr?
So schliessen sich die Kreise.
- Ja.
Regula wohnt mit ihrer Familie im
selben Haus wie das Ehepaar Hohler.
Sie waren die Jungen
und wir die Kinder, die nachkamen.
Dann waren wir die Jungen,
und jetzt kommen die Grosskinder.
Dass die Geschichte bis 80 ging ...
Das ist ziemlich faszinierend.
Und jetzt die Generation von Adina
mit dem Cello.
Wenn die beiden
oben manchmal Cello spielen,
muss ich meistens etwas
für den Kindergarten vorbereiten
und höre durch die Decke,
wie die zwei spielen.
Adina ist die elfjährige Tochter
seines Sohnes Kaspar.
Grossvater und Enkelin
üben jede Woche gemeinsam.
Das ist ein neues Ensemblelied.
- Aha.
Du musst die erste Stimme spielen,
weil ich die zweite spiele.
Gut. Und ...
* Adina macht Geräusche. *
Was?
Ah, eins, zwei, drei, vier - eins.
So.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier - eins.
Ein paar Lieder
muss er erst alleine spielen,
bevor er sie mit mir spielen kann.
Aber generell
kann er besser Cello spielen.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich zupfe nicht gerne,
mein Finger ist ganz heiss.
Du hast es gut gemacht.
Die Lieder der Cellostunde
kenne meisten ich besser,
da ich sie ja mehr übe.
Er verliert immer die Notenblätter.
Das ist aber noch nicht ...
Super ...
Das ist ...
Ein paar Lieder
mussten wir schon dreimal kopieren.
Das ewig lange Pizzicato ...
Das ist kein Pizzicato.
- Eben, gezupft.
Aber das ist kein Pizzicato.
Es bedeutet das Gleiche,
aber ist ja egal.
Es geht ja mehr um Töne
als um Worte.
Aber das machst du ganz gut.
Um Morde?
- Um Worte.
Ich habe verstanden "um Morde".
- Ah, nein.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Es war fast gut. Aber gut genug.
(Durchsage) Nächster Halt: Olten.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Gleichfalls.
Gehen Sie nach Olten?
- Ja.
Zur Arbeit?
- An eine Sitzung. Bahnhofsbuffet.
Bahnhofsbuffet?
- Ja.
Das berühmte.
- Genau.
Jeder Besuch in seiner Heimatstadt
löst bei Franz Hohler
positive Gefühle aus.
Hierherzukommen,
über die Brücke zu gehen,
auf die Altstadt zu blicken,
ist immer ein Heimkommen.
Ich bin in Olten aufgewachsen,
wohne aber
schon länger nicht mehr dort.
Ich habe rückblickend
ein Lied geschrieben,
das heisst "Olten und Umgäbig".
# Vode Brugg isch me
obenabe gchöpflet,
# wemer zwöfli gsi isch oder meh.
# De Herr Hess het am Mittwuch
mit em Chilechor probet,
# im Gloggehof
het me gjasset nachher.
# Im Schöngrund het dr Herr Kuenz
Sinfonie komponiert.
# Die sind schön gsi,
nur zum Spiele ächli z schwär.
In diesem Haus wuchs Franz zusammen
mit seinem älteren Bruder Peter auf.
Ich war so an Büchern interessiert,
dass ich,
noch bevor ich Bücher lesen konnte,
ich mit etwa fünf Jahren
hochkletterte,
weil ich wahrscheinlich ein Buch
von weiter oben hervorholen wollte.
Und was passiert?
Das ganze Regal kippt und die Bücher
fallen auf  mich runter.
Ich falle unter den Schreibtisch.
Man sieht noch heute die Stelle,
wo das Bücherregal
auf den Schreibtisch schlug.
Ohne den Schreibtisch
hätte es mich erschlagen.
Bücher und das Bücherregal
hätten mich mit fünf erschlagen.
Im Historischen Museum Olten rückt
die Eröffnung der Ausstellung näher.
(Lift) Etage 3.
Schön, "Wegen Ausstellungswechsel
geschlossen!".
Es ist schön, wenn man sagen kann,
dass ich der Wechsel bin.
Guten Morgen.
Letzte Besprechung
mit den Ausstellungsmacherinnen.
Hoi, Franz.
Also die ...
Kannst du uns sagen,
woher diese Engelsperücke kommt?
Ja, die kommt aus meinem Programm
"Im Turm zu Babel".
Dort gab es eine Stelle,
in der ein Engel im Himmel
angesprochen wurde.
Danach gab er bekannt, dass Himmel
und Hölle fusioniert hätten.
Damit mehr Synergien möglich sind.
* Telefonklingeln *
Sie möchten mit dem Chef reden?
Der ist leider auf Geschäftsreise.
Worum geht's? Sie wurden abgewiesen?
Da sind Sie nicht der Einzige.
Was war denn ausschlaggebend?
Ein Fehltritt
mit einer anderen Frau.
Das hat sich der Chef
auch schon einmal geleistet.
Holen Sie bei einem der Erzengel
ein Formular F.
Füllen Sie das sorgfältig aus,
reichen Sie es beim Rekursengel ein,
der wird es der Wiedererwägungs-
kommission vorlegen.
Es kann eine Weile dauern,
der Pendenzenberg ist gross.
Und der Vorsitz
hat der Heilige Stagnatius.
* Lachen *
Und noch beim Heft
"Berühmte Schweizer" ...
Ja.
Ist das ein Schulheft
oder ein privates von dir?
Nein, das habe ich für mich gemacht,
weil es mich interessierte.
Ich hatte das Gefühl ...
Ich darf es ja anfassen.
Ich denke,
das war Ende Primarschule.
General Guisan -
ihn fotografierte ich noch.
Und zwar, als er in Olten
über die Bahnhofsbrücke kam,
wo wir vorhin waren.
Ich wusste, dass er kommt, und lag
mit der Kamera auf der Lauer.
Ich war etwas enttäuscht,
dass er keine Uniform trug.
Der Zweite von rechts ist er.
Gleich gegenüber
vom Historischen Museum
befindet sich das Kunstmuseum Olten.
Hier tritt Franz Hohler
als Kurator in Erscheinung.
Aus den Beständen der Kunstsammlung
hat er seine Lieblingsbilder
ausgewählt.
Arbeit empfindet Hohler
als etwas Positives.
Ich sehe Arbeit als Freude an.
Wenn möglich.
Natürlich gibt es Momente,
in denen man
durch Zeitdruck erpresst wird.
Aber die Arbeit an sich
ist für mich ein Glück.
Bei Klassenzusammenkünften
sitze ich neben etlichen ehemaligen
Chefärzten und Zahnärzten.
Aus dem Gymi.
Oder neben ehemaligen Lehrern.
Die können ihren Beruf
schon lange nicht mehr ausüben,
obwohl sie ihn sicher gerne machten.
Und ich kann selber bestimmen,
wann ich aufhöre.
Ich habe es immer
als Privileg empfunden,
dass ich noch weiterarbeiten kann.
Dadurch,
dass ich schon so alt werden konnte,
erlebe ich die Momente,
dass mir Dinge, die ich früher tat,
völlig lebendig entgegenkommen,
weil sie immer noch gefragt sind.
Da denke ich,
vielleicht bleibt das noch gefragt.
Beispielsweise meine Ballade
zum Weltuntergang von 1973.
Die ist 50 Jahre alt,
aber die wird durch die
gegenwärtige Situation des Klimas
zu einem aktuellen Text.
"Da kratzen sich die Wissenschaftler
meistens in den Haaren."
"Sie sagen, in 10, in 20 Jahren,
in 50 vielleicht
oder auch erst in 100."
"Ich selber
habe mich anders besonnen."
"Ich bin sicher, der Weltuntergang,
meine Damen und Herren,
hat schon begonnen."
In ihrem Garten
treffen sich Franz und Ursula
regelmässig mit den Familien
ihrer beiden Söhne Lukas und Kaspar.
Enkelin Adina bereitet schon mal das
Terrain für den gemeinsamen Brunch.
Es kommen immer wieder Wespen.
Ich freue mich,
wenn die Familie kommt.
Das ist sehr schön.
Wenn die Söhne mit der Familie
kommen, die Enkelkinder.
Und man sieht,
dass das Leben weitergeht.
Ja.
Auch ohne uns.
- Auch ohne uns.
Habari za asubuhi.
- Salam.
Hey. Nice to see you.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Oh, wow.
(Mann) I cut you some.
* Friedliche Gitarrenmusik *
Let's sit here.
Heiss.
- Ja, es ist heiss.
Willst du auch?
- Ja, gerne.
Gut.
(Hohler) Oder eben auch ...
Allora.
Sprache und das Spielen mit Sprache
war immer ...
... natürlich um uns herum.
Ich merke es jetzt sehr,
da ich mit Camira zusammen bin.
Sie kommt aus Kenia,
wo man Swahili spricht.
Das hat ihn sehr interessiert.
"Was ist das für eine Sprache?"
Er hat sich auch immer erkundigt,
ob Camira
ihm Material bringen könnte
oder sie das
zusammen anschauen könnten.
Vor zwei Wochen wurde meine Frau 40.
Da hielt er eine Rede, wie er es
an solchen Anlässen immer tut.
Und die Rede war auf Swahili.
Er hielt wirklich eine Rede
auf Swahili.
Er überraschte damit alle.
Ich kann sehr gut sagen "habari
yako" oder "habari za asubuhi".
Und wenn dann Zumali sagt
"bye-bye, kesho",
weiss ich, dass er "morgen" meint.
Morgen.
Yes.
Ich mache gerne ...
- Du dekodierst die Grammatik.
Ich versuche,
mir die Konjugationen zu merken.
Und Dinge wie Singular, Plural.
Thematisch.
Er ist effektiv ein Perfektionist.
Das trägt manchmal
ein wenig seltsame Blüten.
Er hat sich verschiedentlich ...
Er hat sich Entsorgungsverletzungen
zugezogen,
weil er im Perfektionismus
von einer Olivenölflasche
dieses Metallteil lösen wollte
und sich dabei mit dem Küchenmesser
in den Daumen schnitt.
Das wurde fast zu einem Klassiker.
Und meistens war es
vor irgendwelchen Celloauftritten,
dass er dann Probleme
mit dem Daumen hatte.
Gerade das Entsorgen ...
Das ist ein Thema,
worüber wir uns
auch ein wenig lustig machten.
Dass alles
korrekt entsorgt werden muss.
Oder dass alle
noch so winzigen Essensreste
in einem Minitupperware
im Kühlschrank landen,
auch wenn es
nur noch eine Olive ist.
Das ist vielleicht
die Seite des Perfektionismus,
die ich nicht teile,
oder die vielleicht schon
beinahe ins Manische kippt,
sagen wir mal.
* Er spricht undeutlich. *
Bei der goldenen Hochzeit,
die wir zu unserem Schrecken
ja feierten,
da sagtest du doch,
wir seien
nicht so lange verheiratet gewesen,
da ich mindestens die Hälfte
der Zeit weg war.
Also sei es wahrscheinlich
erst die silberne Hochzeit.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
# Mengisch machi Züg ab
und d Familie liidet derbi.
# "Muesch etzt is Färnseh
go spiele?" seit d Frau
# und luegt truurig dri.
# "Weisch", sägi nachher
und hüeschtle,
# "Es isch eifach
nid angersch gange."
# Sie hei so lieb gfragt u gschribe,
i hase nid chönne la hange.
# S si alli so nätt.
S si alli so nätt.
# Wenn di Lüt gsächtisch,
# wo alli da i das trischte
Leutschebach ufecho si.
# S si alli so nätt.
Welche Erinnerung haben die Söhne
trotz seiner häufigen Abwesenheit?
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Er war im Hintergrund,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass er nicht präsent
oder ansprechbar war.
Es ist auch eine Frage des Typs.
Bei uns in der Familie
gab es immer wieder Situationen,
in denen Ursula und ich
und sehr leidenschaftlich stritten.
Und Franz und Kaspar gingen
ins Wohnzimmer Schach spielen.
Holundersirup ist ein Running Gag
seit Jahrzehnten.
Schon als wir Kinder waren,
gab es das jedes Jahr.
Also selbst gemachten Holundersirup,
was bis in eine Gestaltung ging.
Es ist ein Bemühen darum,
alles perfekt zu machen.
Oder auch
eine schöne Welt zu kreieren.
# Doch das macht alles nüt,
solangs Summer isch
# und mer dusse sitzt
amene länge Tisch.
Und jetzt mit der Kamera
wird geschwenkt.
Sonst macht man einen Schnitt,
aber hier wird geschwenkt,
wegen des Reims aufs Sommergetränk.
Einen Schwenker aufs Sommergetränk.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es Ihnen geht,
aber wenn ich mich
plötzlich mehr für
Holunderblütensirup interessiere
als fürs Weltgeschehen,
merke ich, dass es Sommer wird.
# Denn isch d Zyt vode Glaces
und dr Erdbeershakes.
# Vode Holzchohlegrill
und de Hohrüggesteak.
# D Chind chöme fröhlicher hei
us dr Schuel.
# D Bundesverfassig
liit im Liegestuehl.
In Olten besucht Franz Hohler
die Christkatholische Kirche.
Hier war er in seiner Jugend
oft engagiert.
Ich bin zwar nicht gläubig,
aber die Kirchen
haben eine wichtige Funktion.
Kirchen sind ein Ort,
wo man in jeder Stadt reingehen
und etwas nachdenken kann.
Die Kirche muss immer auch
für die Benachteiligten da sein.
Ich musizierte viel in der Kirche,
begleitete auch den Chor.
Manchmal spielte ich auch Solostücke
oder zusammen mit der Orgel.
Von der Sakristei
sah man hinter den Altar.
Der Altar vorne ist wunderbar.
Brokatdecke, Strahlenkranz,
Tabernakel etc.
Hinten stand einfach ein Putzeimer
mit einer Bürste.
Und der ganze Altar unverputzt.
Das war ein solcher Gegensatz.
Vorne der Altar,
und was dahinter war.
Dieses Bild
kam mir immer wieder in den Sinn.
Das blieb mir das ganze Leben.
Vorderseite und Rückseite.
Auf der Empore der Kirche
sind private Fotos von Franz Hohler
ausgestellt.
Hier kann die weitgehend
unbekannte Seite von ihm als Fotograf
und Chronist des Alltags
entdeckt werden.
Das ist Zilli, der Hund
des Nachbarn, der Bauer war.
Der kam mit der Vorderpfote
in die Mähmaschine.
Aber wie man sieht,
haben sie es wieder gerichtet.
Die Fotos stammen aus der Zeit,
als wir in Uetikon am See wohnten.
Das ist Ursula, meine Frau.
Das ist Dorli Meier,
die Frau des Schriftstellers
Gerhard Meier,
die den Kiosk in Niederbipp betrieb.
* Lachen *
Das ist Lukas, mein älterer Sohn.
Da war er noch ein Junge.
Und das ist "Mord auf der Laube".
Das ist von unseren ...
Ich weiss nicht mehr genau,
wie es dazu kam,
aber die machten ein Spiel,
bei dem der Bär dran glauben musste.
Es ist eindrücklich.
Ich habe eigentlich das Gefühl,
ich werde nicht 80, sondern 160.
Wenn ich sehe, was in diesem Leben
alles Platz hatte.
Grüezi, Herr Hohler.
- Grüezi.
Freut mich sehr.
- Gleichfalls.
Das ist toll, ich habe schon
die Destination gesehen.
Was wir extra gemacht haben,
haben Sie aber noch nicht gesehen.
Nein.
Ah, da!
Dieser Bus fährt bis im November.
(Frau) Die lieben Schülerinnen
haben vor einem halben Jahr
diese Zeichnungen
zum "Totemügerli" gemacht.
Sie wollen unbedingt aufs Foto.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Rückt etwas zusammen.
Machen wir das so. Ha!
* Jubel *
Bring ein paar Ballone.
Ja.
- Ja, bravo!
In ihrem Garten blickt Franz
zusammen mit seiner Frau Ursula
auf seine Anfänge zurück
und zieht Bilanz.
Als ich jung war,
legte ich mir
zwei Biografien zurecht.
Und die eine war:
Ich studiere,
werde Mittelschullehrer
und schreibe daneben
vielleicht auch ein bisschen.
Die zweite Biografie war:
Ich versuche mit meinen Ideen
und von meinen Ideen zu leben.
Für die zweite Biografie
entschied ich mich mit 22
und brach das Studium ab.
Wenn ich zurückschaue,
muss ich sagen, dass es mich freut,
dass das gelang.
So.
Jetzt kommt das Endprodukt
des Holundersirups.
Der Holundersirup
ist jetzt in dieser Flasche.
Man lässt den Holunder zuerst ...
Die Dolden, die man abgelesen hat,
lässt man 24 Std. in 1 l Wasser.
Dann nimmt man
die Holunderdolden heraus.
Die Blüten.
Und dann ...
... kocht man das
mit 1 kg weissem Zucker auf.
Bis jetzt war es einfach
eine normale Flasche.
Wenn ich die Flasche
dann jemandem schenke,
mache ich
noch eine kleine Zeichnung drauf.
Ja.
Da unten haben wir
einen hässlichen ...
... einen hässlichen Barcode,
den ich nicht wegkriege.
Jetzt machen wir Kunst draus.
Voilà.
Das hätten wir.
Alles selber gemacht.
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023